i live in a big beautiful mansion  beautiful family yeah this dude's come  pick me up where are you taking me  brother we're going to move around them  today wolverhampton i left the midlands  why am i going to wolverhampton to run a  training program to teach you how to  make money because you know what people  say to me sami if you made so much money  in property why you're not teaching  people but you know what you'll realize  when you become financially free you  think you're just gonna lie on a beach  forever and do nothing else but that  gets boring after a while so what you'll  do is you'll become financially free and  then you'll start pulling other people  up a lot of satisfaction in that man  let's go bro i'll see you later